foreign
okay
I'll give it to you straight
we need at least four trillion dollars
per year by 2030 to avert a climate
crisis
and right now that money simply isn't
flowing at the rate we need to keep this
planet habitable
now I work with a lot of banks and
investors and everyone who I talk to
and I work with some of the leading ones
around the world they get what needs to
be done
they're aware of the climate risks and
they're actually really excited about
the unprecedented opportunities to
finance the green economy of the future
and here's the good news
over 450 financial institutions around
the world have committed to aligning
their financing to Net Zero by 2050.
and collectively these financial
institutions manage over 130 trillion
dollars
okay so we need trillions we've got
trillions problem solved right shortest
Ted Talk ever
I wish that were the case
but now as we're working to deliver on
those commitments it's actually proving
to be really hard like really hard to
deploy real money into real technologies
that will actually really decarbonize
the world
and as a result too much of that money
it's sitting on the sidelines
waiting to be put to work
but I think we can change that
and it's not even what I think I know we
can
because it's based on what banks and
investors tell me about what they need
to go fast and go far
and what they need is help from people
like you and me
so to bring this idea to life let's zoom
in on one part of the economy one that
we can all relate to it's close to home
let's talk about housing
because believe it or not
the challenges we're facing with housing
and the challenges we're facing with
climate are inextricably linked so as we
solve for one we can solve for the other
you see we're facing two concurrent
challenges right now with housing on one
hand there's an affordability challenge
there's just a scarcity of homes that
are affordable right now
here in the United States there's a
scarcity of over 7 million homes that
people who live at or below the poverty
line can afford to rent
and the other affordability challenge is
it's less affordable than ever before to
live in one because they're so energy
inefficient
these older less energy efficient homes
tend to be in black and brown
neighborhoods due to the structural
nature of poverty and get this a recent
study found that the average renter who
is Black pays over 250 dollars more per
year in utility bills than one who is
white
okay so we need to build a lot more
affordable housing great
but that's when we run into the climate
challenge
because the buildings that we live in
are one of the leading contributors to
the greenhouse gases that are fueling
climate change
and if we take a business as usual
approach to just building all this
housing we'll only exacerbate the
climate challenge think about the
emissions from all that cement and steel
and concrete that goes into a high-rise
for example
so pretty sticky challenge
but that's why I love working in
sustainable finance and investing
because we get to take challenges like
this and transform them to opportunities
specifically financing opportunities
opportunities to deploy debt Equity
grants by governments investors and
Banks and in the housing sector the
financing opportunities are enormous we
recently did a study we found over a
trillion dollars worth of things that
Banks can Finance to lower the emissions
associated with our housing
okay great so what will it take how can
we actually get this done
well here's the catch
you see Banks work within prescribed
risk thresholds and some of the things
we need most like replacements for that
high carbon cement steel concrete
they're being developed by companies
right now that are still relatively
early stage and might not yet fit within
those risk thresholds
similarly building affordable homes in a
low-income Community or a low-income
country might not reach the risk that
return thresholds that investors are
looking for
when I talk to Banks and investors they
say they need the right type of public
policies they need the right type of
capital and they need demand in order to
put this money to work
so that's where you and I can come in
because there are some simple moves that
you and I can do that can help to create
the conditions that will allow this
money to flow I'm going to talk you
through these different moves and as I'm
talking just bear in mind
these moves are not exclusive to housing
we could apply this playbook in any
sector where we need faster climate
action
okay let's Dive In
the first thing that we can do to really
move these trillions of dollars is make
the climate housing connection matter to
government
governments have a huge role to play in
climate Finance but when I talk to Banks
and investors there's one particular
form of government funding that they say
would make a huge difference and it's
called Blended or catalytic Finance
you see
the private sector Banks and investors
they have a lot of capital
but not necessarily always the right
risk appetite on the other hand
governments are willing to take some
risks especially for things like the
climate or social equity but they don't
have as much capital
so it Blended Finance involves is
governments deploying their Finance in
instruments like guarantees or more
concessional forms of Lending
and this allows that private sector
Finance to flow when the governments
take on more of that risk
and this kind of Blended or catalytic
Finance has proven to be tremendously
effective in areas like affordable
housing where a little bit of government
money can go a long way
okay great so that's how we can get some
money flowing but there's more that we
need from governments and I call them
the three PS public policies programs
permits
and to bring this to life let me tell
you a story of a bank that I'm working
with
they have bold Ambitions they want to
bring all the financing in line with Net
Zero targets by 2050. including their
financing for homes
and as we worked to bring
this ambition to life we ran into three
key challenges
in a lot of the markets where they
operate the right public policies just
weren't in place
minimum Energy Efficiency standards just
didn't exist
moreover the programs to incentivize
homeowners to put solar panels on the
roof or to retrofit the homes the kind
of things that the banks was willing to
finance they just weren't available at
sufficient scale
and finally when the bank was looking
for Big Ticket things to finance like
entirely new housing developments that
were affordable and low emissions they
found that projects were held up in
permitting
and so their good intentions remain
stalled and so did the money
it's where people like you and I can
come in we the voters and constituents
because we can demand that governments
do this
we can demand that they put in place at
financing those programs those permits
and look I get it right now it's a
little bit of a complicated time at for
many countries at the national level
around climate change policy
but the exciting thing about housing is
a lot of the changes that we need are
super local
we're small numbers of Voters can
actually make a huge difference
so let's do this let's put climate and
importantly actions that drive climate
Finance at the top of the agenda for
every local government let's write to
our local officials and say hey look the
banks and investors they're real they're
ready to put money to work and if we can
just put in place the right policies
programs permits that money can come to
our community
let's back the candidates at back
climate action and importantly let's
show up to vote
okay that's the first move we can
mobilize governments
but if we want to mobilize big money we
also have to look at the big balance
sheets so here's the second move
if you have an insurance policy or a
pension this one's for you
you see pension plans insurance
companies they're managing huge balance
sheets
they're often referred to as
institutional investors
and these institutional investors
they're managing your money for the long
run
and the good news is that in recent
years they have increasingly begun to
appreciate that the long-term risks
associated with climate change present a
material risk to their ability to manage
your money and so they've started taking
action to manage those climate risks
well thanks to the pandemic and the
recent focus on racial equity
they're now appreciating that social
inequities also create these long-term
Financial risks and they're ready to
step up and take action like here's some
good news in 2020 investors financed
over 140 billion dollars worth of social
bonds
that's up from 17 billion just the year
before
what are social bonds their bonds the
use of proceeds can be used towards
addressing social inequities including
things like affordable housing
so when I talk to these investors and
ask them okay you're doing billions
that's great but what would it take to
get to trillions they say it all comes
down to having a mandate
a mandate to better integrate these
environmental or social considerations
into how they manage your money the
mandate to actually put the money to
work
so how can we give them that mandate
well there's two ways one is insurance
companies and pension plans are
increasingly giving you options to move
your money from a general pool into a
more dedicated one that manages money
with greater environmental and social
considerations in mind
and if you don't have that option demand
it
large pension plans insurance companies
they have teams whose job it is to
listen to your concerns I know because
that was one of my first jobs out of
college to just answer phones for a
large pension plan in Canada and the
more we speak up and influence these
large investors who are managing our
money and make clear how we want them to
consider environmental and social causes
the more of a mandate that they will
have to put those trillions to work
okay so first move is governments second
is the institutional investors
the third move is ourselves
we need to create the demand for these
Greener Solutions let me give you a few
examples
you know most banks they'll offer a
discount for your mortgage if it meets
minimum Energy Efficiency standards but
guess what
few people take them up on that offer
similarly I worked for a large real
estate investment company they were
willing to do the right thing they were
willing to retrofit their buildings and
build entirely new ones with new
materials that would make it a low
carbon building altogether
you know what they told me
aside from a few markets in Europe they
just weren't seeing the demand
so I think we can take some inspiration
from the other aspects of our lives like
the food we eat or the vehicles we drive
where we have shown Banks and investors
that it's worth financing alternatives
to meat or electric vehicles let's bring
that shift now into the homes in which
we live and let's show them that it's
worth financing more energy efficient
lower carbon homes
so when you're out to buy or rent your
next home ask about Energy Efficiency
and even better ask about the overall
carbon footprint
so those are three things we can do we
can activate governments we can mobilize
these large institutional investors we
can create the demand ourselves
you know as anyone in finance would hate
to admit it money doesn't make the world
go round
this big beautiful
blue and green planet that we live on
it's been spinning on its axis for long
before we were here
and we'll continue to do so for long
after we've gone
what money can do is influence just how
long we'll be here to enjoy the ride
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]